Voiceover: So, I claimed in the last
video that we made a $5 risk-free profit
by spending $38 to buy a call and a bond
and we got $43 by shorting a stock
and essentially writing a put option.
What I want to do in this video is verify
that we really do have
all of our basis covered.
So let's just think about all
of the different scenarios
for the underlying stock
price at option expiration
because that's the date
that we care about.
So let's take this situation
where the stock just becomes
where the stock just goes to 0.
In that situation the call
that we own is worthless.
The call is worthless.
No reason why you'd want to
exercise the option to buy it
for $35 when the stock is worth 0.
But the good thing is, is that when
we now have to cover our short.
Remember, when you short something
you're borrowing the stock and selling it
and in the future you have to buy
the stock to cover your short.
To buy the stock and return it
to whomever you borrowed it from.
So now, we can spend $0.
We can now spend $0, $0 to buy stock
and essentially give it back
to whom we borrowed it from
or should cover the short.
To buy stock to cover or unwind short.
To cover the short.
The bad thing is, is that
put option that we wrote.
Remember, we wrote it.
We sold the put option.
We're giving someone
else the right to sell
to sell the stock to us for $35
and if the stock price is worth $0
they're going to exercise that option.
Because they can then, they
can buy the stock for 0
and they can sell it to us for $35.
So, we have to spend, we
have to spend $35 to buy ...
to kind of buy the stock from put holder.
From put holder.
But the good thing is, is
that we have this bond,
we own this bond that's now worth $35.
We have a $35 bond, 35.
We have a $35 bond.
So we can use the $35
bond to spend the $35
such to give the $35 to the holder of
the put and everything cancels out.
We can still keep our original $5.
So, that's the situation where
the stock price went to 0.
What about the situation where the
stock price goes to something crazy?
Let's say the stock price goes to 70.
So, the stock price goes up.
We draw a column over here.
So, now let's think about the scenario
where the stock price goes to 70.
Now all of a sudden the
call option we have,
remember it's an option
to buy the stock at $35.
The call, the call is worth, is worth $35.
The call is worth $35.
We have a bond that's
going to be worth $35.
A bond worth 35.
The put option is worthless so the
person who we wrote the put for
they won't exercise it.
So, the put is worthless.
The put is worthless but we
still have to cover our short.
We have to buy back the stock
and return the stock to
whomever we borrowed it from
and now to cover our short, to buy
the stock is going to cost us $70.
So, we're going to have to use this $70,
the $35 from the call
and $35 from the bond
to actually cover our short positions.
So $70 to buy stock and cover short.
What you'll see is I just picked
kind of a low, a low stock price
and a high stock price but no
matter what the stock price is
you're going to be able to
cover all of your obligations
and break even at expiration and
keep your original risk-free $5.
Now the reality of the situation is that
opportunities like this seldom exist
because frankly people can
write computer programs
to find these arbitrage opportunities
and just exploit them
really, really, really fast.